people do actively say like political
correctness is killing comedy especially
on college campuses and it's very very
interesting because I think part of it's
true I think I'm a very notoriously
positive comic I think especially with
the show I do it's like very very
inclusive we just threw an episode
called the gender-fluid polyamorous prom
that was all about just including every
lifestyle I'm the I think notoriously on
the PC end of things and I still get
feedback from people that's like really
like in attack mode
about issues and I'm like wow I live on
the fringe of I live on the liberal
progressive fringe of comedy kind of
notoriously it I get attacked sometimes
so I can't imagine people who are a
little bit more conservative I think
less I think maybe some of the more
blue-collar comics take it on the chin
but it's a very very interesting thing
because comics tend to have this
knee-jerk reaction of or creative people
and our work builds by doing it on stage
again and again we should be allowed to
say and do whatever we want and I think
there's a lot of truth to that
I think comics do need permission to
fail I think comics do need permission
to go up and try stuff I've said some
things on stage where the crowd was like
whoa no that's and I never say it again
because that's the feedback I get and
there's a part of me that knows so much
of its internet driven if somebody had a
camera on and put that joke on the
internet and it went wild I'd be like no
that's why I was I tried it that's why I
went and tried it cuz to know that it
wouldn't work and then it would bug
everybody out that's why I wouldn't want
to do it again or at least fix the parts
that turn everybody off so it is tough
but I think the the other side of the
coin that I think we as comics need to
maybe cop to a little bit more it's like
we are allowed to say whatever we want
but also people are allowed to get as
offended as they're going to get they're
allowed to and we don't have to like it
they don't have to like us and that's
totally fine I think the the Troublesome
point like I have a fresh Sam Morril
great comic friend of mine I know him
through the comedy scene we're not the
best friends in the world but I think
he's great and he's such a sweet guy and
he made a joke
once at a show that was really late at
night that was billed as a really
aggressively sort of like dirty risque
show and he made a joke that involved a
topic of rape and I don't think he'd say
it was the most well thought-out
polished material and someone someone
wrote about it on a blog and it really
blew up and it really blew up and it's
tough because it's like there are
certain topics that shouldn't be joked
about at the same time if a joke about a
topic can hit it can actually be one of
the most powerful tools to fight back
against things we don't like so I really
felt like man this guy Sam is a sweet
dude I know him he's a sweet dude and he
tried to joke at a show that was meant
to be awful material and he's getting
slammed for being awful and he never
wanted to put he was never gonna record
that for an album and put it on a
special so I remember thinking that was
like that was so that's like the
nightmare scenario for a comedian and
it's not totally fair but too many
comedians use that as an excuse to just
say whatever they want with no
consequence I don't think that's cool
either people want to get up and just
say crazy things if you want to say
stuff that's like racist homophobic
sexist just say like well I'm a comic
man we're the truth tellers in society
we just say whatever we want you can't
judge us for and it's like well you
can't and you can say whatever you want
but if a crowd turns on you and if a
think piece gets written then you got
bad intentions you might have to just
own that if you want to put that stuff
out there you might just have to own it
it's all valid people's reactions are as
valid as our right to create so I've
seen situations that I think are really
unfair to comics seen situations where I
think comics are really unrealistic
about what creative expression and what
the artistic freedom what that entails I
think there's a middle ground I think
there is there's unfair sides to both
people comics need to be able to
experiment people need to be able to
express discontent and too many people I
think hide on the fringes of those as an
excuse to attack and I think there's a
middle ground where artistic freedom can
live healthily and people respect it but
yeah I get mad I hear too many comics I
kind
I leaned on that side right here comics
going like well I said this thing and
people just need to shut up and it's
like well they don't need to shut up
it's a little extreme you said something
kind of awful maybe you can take the
note and rewrite that bit a little bit I
think at the end of the day I'll always
dig colleges because I think young
people give you good feedback I think
they're always you always have to if I
ever lose touch with like if my jokes
ever stop hitting with young people I'll
probably retire immediately because it
means I'm washed-up and also those
college gigs they pay great cash man
you